- Dr. Ranbir Sartain was born in 1953 or 1954.
He mentions that he studied under Michael Myers
clinical psychiatrist, Dr. Samuel Loomis just
before Loomis passed away. This would mean that
Dr. Sartain was likely a graduate student
at the time, which puts him in his mid to
late 20s. We don't know anything about Sartain's
childhood, but his accent suggests that he may
be from Turkey. His morgue tag says he died in
Izmir, Turkey, which is obviously wrong, so I’m
guessing Turkey was actually his place of birth.
It's never explicitly stated when Dr. Loomis died,
but it's assumed that he died of natural causes
in this timeline. His actor, Donald Pleasance,
died in 1995, so we can assume Sartain took over
the job around then. Dr. Sartain would follow
a path similar to his teacher, but his obsession
with Michael Myers would eventually go too far. If
you want to know how Dr. Sartain's obsession with
his patient compares but also greatly differs from
his mentor, Dr. Samuel Loomis, just how common it
is for doctors to become obsessed with their own
patients, and what drove Dr. Sartain to attempt
murder, stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
Welcome to "Horror History." Not much is
known about Ranbir Sartain prior to his
work with Dr. Loomis, but he was
likely a good student growing up,
as he got into a well-respected graduate program
at the University of Illinois to study psychology.
He eventually would go on to study under Dr.
Loomis and after his death lobbied to take over
his work with Michael Myers. This is a little
trick that the "Halloween" writers used for
almost all of the new characters in the 40-year
timeline. The majority of newcomers work under
a more familiar character in some way to make
it feel like they're connected to the original
story. Frank Hawkins worked under Sheriff
Brackett. Karen Nelson was raised by Laurie
Strode. One thing about Dr. Sartain's past is
very clear. As time went on, his obsession with
figuring out Michael Myers grew more extreme, even
surpassing that of his mentor. From what we see,
he doesn't seem to have much of a personal life
outside of his studies. Besides Michael Myers,
the only thing that he's shown to take
interest in is analyzing his patents' dreams.
- Any dreams?
- Nope.
- [Sartain] Sometimes we don't remember our
dreams. But if we are dreaming some just before
we wake up, we remember those. That's right.
- That patient, who is in the confines of
a sanitarium, is so bored by Sartain he's
actively reconsidering being crazy. It's
possible that Dr. Sartain had an interest
in serial killers in general, leading to his
fascination with Michael. I say this because
it seems like he came from pretty far away
to study The Shape, as opposed to Loomis,
who already lived and worked in Illinois.
In a conversation with Officer Hawkins,
Sartain says what intrigued him in his studies
was the effect of tragedy on the victimizer. I
feel like that's something I talk about a lot when
covering villains on "Horror History." Oftentimes,
the horror movies and novels themselves focus
more on how the victim reacts to the horror,
but Sartain and, I guess, myself prefer to analyze
the bad guy. Maybe our boy Ranbir should have just
become a content creator. His desire to understand
Michael isn't so different from what drives most
audiences to the genre of true crime. According to
BBC's "Science Focus," "evolutionary psychologists
say that we're drawn to these tales because
major crime has played a significant part in
human society since our hunter-gatherer days.
It's in our nature to be highly attuned to
criminal misdemeanors, and we instinctively want
to discover the who, what, when, and where so we
can find out what makes criminals tick and to
better protect ourselves and our kin." This is
a human instinct that most human beings have
to a certain extent. So now you can tell your
local anti-horror snowflake: up yours, liking dark
things is literally human nature. However, in Dr.
Sartain's case, it's much more complicated than
just a typical morbid fascination. To understand
how his obsession with Michael Myers started to
veer off from just primal instinct, I'm gonna look
to the Key West in the 1930s, where another doctor
had a similar relationship with his patient.
(old timey music)
In 1930, a physician by the name of Carl Tanzler
encountered a patient named Maria Elena Milagro
de Hoyos, or as I'll be calling her from
now on, Dear Maria. ♪ I got your picture ♪
- When she came into the hospital that Dr. Tanzler
worked at, there was an immediate attraction,
but sadly for her, she was there due to
tuberculosis, which was often fatal at that
time. Tanzler immediately became infatuated with
her, despite her technically being married, and
paid personal house visits, trying every possible
treatment he could think of, showering her with
gifts along the way. Despite Tanzler's efforts,
she died. However, Tanzler's obsession with Dear
Maria would not stop at her death. He paid for
her burial in a pricey mausoleum and visited her
there almost every night for two years. That was
until he lost his job, probably for being too much
of a simp. He crept into the cemetery one night
in 1933, removed her body from the mausoleum,
and took her to an old hollowed-out airplane,
where he used DIY techniques to preserve her,
such as arranging wires and plasters to
maintain her shape, using mortician's wax
to rebuild her face, and adding real human hair
to her scalp. An array of flowers, perfumes,
and antiseptics were placed to try to hide the
smell of her decaying body. After seven years of
maintaining this and doing who knows what else,
Maria's sister discovered the life-sized effigy,
like something out of an Alfred Hitchcock movie.
Dr. Tanzler was exhibiting behaviors associated
with something called obsessive love. Obsessive
love is not officially recognized as a disorder by
DSM-5, the current standard guide for diagnosing
mental disorders, but it can be used as a sign of
other conditions and disorders. Obviously, Dr.
Sartain's case doesn't exactly qualify. He was
not romantically in love with Michael Myers. But
his obsession would follow a similar trajectory,
so it's worth bringing up for comparison. Both
doctors' obsessions led them down a path to
extreme behavior. We could even say the same
about Dr. Loomis. Maybe I've just discovered a
brand-new condition. Let's just call it obsessive
doctor disorder or ODD for short. Dr. Sartain had
to lobby to be able to take over Loomis's studies
on Michael Myers, which he was eventually granted.
But he was not the only one to take a greater
interest in Haddonfield's boogeyman. After
(pensive music)
After Michael's first escape in 1978, the
state of Illinois became less interested
in rehabilitating him and more interested in
understanding how he ticks so that massacres
could be prevented in the future. Dr. Sartain
took great lengths to try to accomplish this,
but years of failure only made him more driven
to crack the Michael Myers code. He brought
in over 50 clinical psychologists to try to
see Michael, and each had different opinions
about him. During the 40 years of Michael's
second stint of captivity, he rarely spoke,
which Sartain took as a personal preference
rather than a speech disability. At some point,
Smith's Grove Sanitarium rebranded to Smith's
Grove State Hospital, which may have been a
result of Sartain's policies. Every morning, he
did individual check-ins with patients, he tried
to calm them with old music, and he made sure they
got fresh air and sunshine every day by outfitting
space on the world's largest checkerboard.
Despite this, lack of visitors for Michael
limits Sartain's ability to see him react to
different people or environments. He seems jealous
that Loomis saw Michael "in the wild," as Sartain
puts it, because he mentions this multiple times.
- Dr. Loomis was the only one to see him in
the wild. I worked with Michael for years,
but I've never seen him in
an uncontrolled environment.
- With no conclusions drawn after 40 years,
Michael was set to be transferred to a new
facility, Glass Hill, and assigned a new doctor,
which Dr. Sartain obviously isn't pleased with.
- Glass Hill is a pit of hell.
For years, he's been kept here
to be studied. I suppose the state has lost
interest in discovering anything further.
- I can imagine that at this point, he lost
hope, because his entire life's work was
about to be for nothing. That is, until he was
approached by British investigative journalists
Aaron Korey and Dana Haines. They wanted to
speak with Michael, which Sartain saw as a
potential last-ditch opportunity to see a new
side of his patient. So they scheduled a meeting
just before the transfer on October 29th, 2018.
This is where Loomis and Sartain's respective
obsessions with Michael diverge from one another.
Loomis's obsession was all about stopping Michael
and protecting innocent people from his wrath. He
was perfectly willing to kill Michael to do this-
- [Loomis] My suggestion is termination.
- whereas Sartain would do whatever it took to
keep Michael alive. He seems to be captivated
by everything his patient does and during Aaron
and Dana's visit expresses that despite Michael's
lack of reaction, he is well aware of their
presence and taking in everything that they're
doing. Dr. Sartain allows Aaron to provoke Michael
using the mask from his 1978 rampage but gets no
response. Later that night, when Michael is being
transferred, Sartain exhibits behavior similar to
Karl Tanzler's unstoppable obsession with Maria.
Tanzler didn't let her death stop him from trying
to save her, and Sartain refuses to give up on
Michael, even after losing authority over him.
- Michael Myers is still my patient
until he's in somebody else's care,
so I'm seeing my duty through 'til the end.
- [Zac] In the late night of October 30th, Michael
overtook the bus to escape into the wild.
It's likely that Dr. Sartain played a part in
helping Michael get free. As Michael got away,
he attacked two guards and the bus driver,
with Sartain being left alive but stranded
on the bus in handcuffs... for some reason.
The doctor likely saw this as the two of
them having some kind of bond or silent
agreement. He would help Michael go free,
and in return, Michael would let him
live. Clearly, after all of his studies,
he did not understand Michael Myers. When a man
and his son come across the bus wreck, they get
out to investigate, and the boy shoots Sartain in
the shoulder, despite Sartain literally saying...
- Don't shoot! Aah!
- Sartain is discovered later by
Deputy Hawkins. Barely conscious,
he's able to utter out the words "Did he escape?",
illustrating his top priority before falling
unconscious. He's rushed to the hospital in the
early morning of October 31st. The police would
like to question him about the incident, but
nurses inform them that he lost too much blood,
causing him to drift in and out of consciousness.
However, a gunshot wound is no match for Sartain's
obsession. After a few hours in hospital care,
which happens to be just long enough for Michael
to begin his rampage through Haddonfield,
Sartain catches up with Deputy Hawkins,
where he meets Laurie Strode and, for
lack of a better term, goes full fangirl.
- Laurie Strode.
- [Sheriff Barker] Laurie Strode, meet Dr. Sartain.
- I read everything about
you and Michael. Everything.
- Dr. Sartain expresses this extreme
fascination with Laurie because she's
one of the few people alive who has
seen Michael killing in the wild, which,
as I mentioned earlier, he's very jealous
of. The other survivors are either too young
or they just didn't see very much of him. Being
that Sartain is most familiar with his patient,
Hawkins brings him along to help with
the search. It's here that he exposes
his own obsessive doctor disorder through the
excitement evident when talking about Michael.
- [Sartain] I want to know what he's feeling. I want
to know what pleasure he gets out of killing.
- He even warns Hawkins that Michael is considered
property of the state and must not be harmed,
further solidifying that his motivations
for studying Michael are far different than
Dr. Loomis's. Loomis is what fans of true
crime would refer to as being pro-victim,
whereas Dr. Sartain wouldn't feel out
of place browsing serial killer merch on
Etsy. In the original "Halloween," Loomis was
armed with a gun, so he believed that he didn't
have much to fear when going after Michael.
In Sartain's case, he has a different reason
to believe that he's not in danger. Often, when
serial killers go to prison, they get letters from
people who are essentially fans that desire to be
close to them. According to some experts, these
fans have a sexual attraction, while others don't
believe that it necessarily has to be. According
to forensic psychology professor Katherine
Ramsland, PhD, these fans get the delusion
that they're special to the person so that if
the person escaped, he or she wouldn't harm the
fan. Ramsland attributes this to narcissism.
Given the fact that Michael chose not to kill
Sartain on the bus and the fact that he tries to
comfort Michael prior to the patient transfer-
- Don't worry, Michael. I'll be by your side.
- it seems like Sartain probably has the same
delusions that serial killer pen pals do. It
could also just be a false sense of safety
due to spending so much time around him,
like the countless stories of zookeepers
who let their guard down around dangerous
animals. Whatever the reason, it would not be long
before Sartain had a wild encounter of his own.
(dark music)
After picking up Laurie Strode's
granddaughter, Allyson Nelson,
trembling in fear from her brush with
Michael, Sartain tells citizens to lock
their doors and go inside and for some
reason throws in that he's a doctor.
- I'm a doctor. Lock your doors.
- As if that qualifies him to be an expert on
home safety, even though there's never been a
moment in the history of Michael Myers where he
was deterred by a locked door. Seems as though
he's enjoying being in a position of importance.
Allyson leaves with Hawkins and Sartain,
sitting in the back of the police car and keeping
an eye out for Michael. When they do find him,
Hawkins floors it and slams into Michael. As
he does so, Sartain yells in protest. Sartain
gets out to protect the unconscious Michael while
Hawkins screams at him to get out of the way so he
can shoot. The doctor believes that Michael
is dead or at least says that to discourage
Hawkins from trying to do any more damage. This
is the point where Sartain goes from obsessed
to psychopathically obsessed. He has a hidden
scalpel blade inside his pen, so he does his best
Ezio Auditore on Officer Hawkins, dropping him to
the ground. Up until this point, he had expressed
several times that he really wanted to know what
Michael felt like while killing, so he exclaims-
- [Sartain] So this is what it feels like.
- which solidifies the idea that if
he ever wanted to solve the mystery
of Michael Myers for scientific purposes to
better humanity, that is no longer the case,
because it doesn't make sense to become a
killer in order to try to stop one. Then again,
there are people who spend thousands of dollars
on credit cards so they can save a couple bucks
on airline miles. I just don't take Sartain
to be that much of an idiot. I think he knows
Michael won't be free forever and he's desperate
to learn as much as he can about him for purely
selfish reasons. It's like I said earlier: he
likes to feel important. And it doesn't stop
there. Sartain puts on Michael's mask and stares
at a terrified Allyson through the car window,
just to, as he put it himself, see what it
feels like. After loading Michael into the
back of the locked police car where Allyson is
now trapped, he drives away over Hawkins' body
and tells Allyson that he is bringing Michael to
Laurie Strode to set up a reunion. His theory is
that Michael stays alive to continue hunting
Laurie and that Laurie stays alive to continue
fighting Michael. He also tells Allyson how badly
he wants to hear Michael speak. He is convinced
that only Laurie Strode can bring this out of him.
Off of this information, Allyson devises a plan on
the spot to try to free herself from the back of
the car. She claims that she had heard Michael
speak when he killed her friend and offers him
a deal. If Sartain lets her out, she'll tell him
what Michael said. However, Sartain's excitement
over the possibility over what Michael could've
said completely distracts him. He guesses at
what the supposed spoken word might've been,
like an excited parent who just found out their
kid spoke his first word from the babysitter.
- What was the word? Was it
the sister's name? Judith?
- But before getting his answer, Michael wakes
up and swiftly kicks in Dr. Sartain's seat,
then proceeds to drag the injured psychologist
out of the car. His final moments are the perfect
microcosm for his entire character, because
instead of pleading for his life or showing
any kind of fear at all, he's completely focused
on asking Michael to say something. Right until
the end, his actions are dictated by his ODD, his
obsession to understand his patient. Ultimately,
he does not get into Michael's head,
but Michael's foot gets into his.
I've got more "Horror History" episodes
on other "Halloween" franchise villains,
like the infamous Conal Cochrane and of course the
masked menace himself. Check the playlist for the
complete set. Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring the death bell,
and select all notifications. I will see you
in the next one, assuming we both survive.